[Music]
well it's it's quite simple really I
think if a representational painter
wants to show the things in the picture
and with an abstract painting what in a
sense you're trying to do is make
everything happen at once now the other
day I was in a Bernardo exhibition and
Bernard said was bond as a figurative
painter of course and considered at one
point retrograde an anti modernist
working in the face of abstraction and
cubism and hanging on to the figure
relentlessly hanging on to the figure he
said I want to give the impression that
when you walk into a room you see
everything and nothing and I would say
that I want to show everything all at
once I once read a very interesting
piece of graffiti when I was at
university which said time was invented
to stop everything happening at once
she's quite sweet in an abstract
painting it's a it should be could be
possibly a moment of Revelation and it's
a kind of thinking that takes you out of
context so that's its big advantage
[Music]